questa sera stiamo sentendo tante belle
cose sul futuro sul mondo su quello che
sarà il mondo che sarà tutto nelle
vostre mani nelle mani dei giovani
ma che cos'è che ha mosso il mondo che è
mosso
l'uomo tutti i millenni della sua storia
che cos'è che ha reso speciale morgan
gabriele francesco che abbiamo appena
ascoltato le passioni le passioni e
sogni ma che formano i sogni di che
colore sono ma i sogni possono avere
mille forme colori profumi diversi
quando siamo piccoli hanno energia hanno
la forza dell'energia il colore rosso
della bicicletta che ci hanno regalato
per il compleanno
i sogni possono avere il profumo di un
ricordo o essere sfumati come i colori
di un tramonto i miei sogni per esempio
erano coincidevano con l'orizzonte che
vedevo dalla finestra della mia stanza
erano vicini alla tastiera del
pianoforte che faceva accompagnare le
giornate erano ispirati dai libri che
leggevo che mi portavano lontano
i sogni sono il motore sono il motore
che accende il nostro futuro senza sogni
saremmo spenti la cosa bella dei sogni è
che non hanno limiti sognando superiamo
ogni barriera diventiamo della stessa
consistenza dell'area ma i sogni sono
tenaci tornano tornano tornano sempre ci
fanno compagnia nei momenti duri ci
sostengono nei momenti bui chu si
sollevano quando caliamo può succedere
che quello che abbiamo desiderato che
abbiamo sognato non accada così proprio
come l'avevamo immaginato oppure che la
realtà sia al di sopra di ogni nostra
aspettativa
l'importante è che dentro di noi ci sia
sempre uno stato d'animo pronto ad
accogliere le sfide quando si cresce
i sogni hanno meno colori
viaggiano una velocità ridotta ma questo
non vuol dire che non possiamo
riprendere quota
basta un colpo di reni fiutare l'aria e
cambiare rotta e le mete sconosciute non
previste non studiate possono farci
scoprire nuove strade possono darci
delle sorprese soprattutto farci
superare quelli che pensavamo essere i
nostri limiti
bisogna abbandonarsi abbandonarsi e
nello stesso tempo gestire le proprie
passioni modellarle con rigore per farle
crescere
è questo il segreto la vita è fatta di
occasioni ma non sempre le cose migliori
ci arrivano in una scatola rosa per
questo dobbiamo accettare le sfide e
ricordarci che nelle pieghe dei
cambiamenti che possiamo trovare le
nostre opportunità migliori grazie